Welcome back to Google
Developers Weekly for
September 23, 2013.
I'm Louis Gray, and this is our
highlight reel of what's
happening in the world
of Google Developers
on the set and off.
Strap in, buckle up.
We've got a lot to talk about.
First, beautiful code and
intelligent applications often
lead to happy users, but if an
application or a website
confuses a user, it introduces
friction and it can stop your
startup cold.
Nazmul Idris, a champion for
user experience, stopped by
Root Access with host Don
Dodge to teach us how to
reduce friction and boost
user acquisition.
As you can imagine, here at Team
GDL, we believe strongly
in the power of YouTube
subscriptions.
From New York, Ibrahim Ulukaya
and Kurt Wilms walked us
through how to code and
customize the recently
launched Subscribe button,
bringing your videos to those
users who don't want to miss a
single minute of your content.
We then saw the Google Analytics
duo of Andrew Wales
and Neil Rhodes introduce us
to Google Tag Manager for
Android and iOS, making it
easier to update website data
and mobile apps to measure
traffic and user behavior to
make your products
even better.
And in a new feature here on
GDL, we invited the Google
Enterprise Maps Team for
the first episode
of What in the World?
Dylan and Ryan Thomas, who I
assume are not related, showed
us how to access Google Maps
Engine layers using Maps API
JavaScript.
Keep in mind, this replaces the
map data layer for those
of you who are geocoders.
Looking at my map, it turns out
our next GDL came from the
southern hemisphere from Buenos
Aires, where Nick
[INAUDIBLE]
returned with the latest from
Latin America, talking Chrome
browser extensions.
[SPANISH].
And before the week wrapped, Don
Dodge was back for round
two of Root Access in our
studio, explaining the many
variables behind startup stock
ownership and what founders,
investors, and employees should
expect when they open
the envelopes containing
their options packages.
This is something you have
to get right to keep your
employee morale high.
In addition to all these great
shows, we were invited to live
stream from SFHTML5, the world's
largest HTML5 user
group, featuring many faces that
you recognize from GDL
including Colt McAnlis,
Paul Lewis, Paul
Irish, and Jake Archibald.
The two plus hour event featured
four fantastic talks
covering web performance, and
we've got it all saved for you
here on YouTube.
So cancel your plans tonight.
You've got homework.
And from Italy, Claudio
d'Angelis
talked to us about Dart.
Claudio discussed how to take
advantage of Dart when using
model-driven views and web
components to build your apps.
Very nice.
So as you can see, we've been
hard at work sharing the
latest from all around
Google this week.
The same is true for our
friends at Android, who
dropped five brand new Dev Bytes
episodes for you mobile
developers, and the latest in
the Game On series featuring
Google Games chats' own
Todd Kerpelman.
So find all of those and more
at the Android Developers
YouTube channel and at
developers.googl
e.com/live/android.
Outside the studio, you saw the
demo at Google I/O, and
now you can read the docs and
implement it yourself.
The Instant Buy API for Android
makes it incredibly
easy for your customers to buy
an item and check out as
easily as if they were using
the Google Play store.
No manual entry of billing
or shipping info
means happier customers.
The Chrome team has added to its
collection of dashboards
with new CSS Metrics chart.
Using anonymous opt-in stats
from Chrome, the new dashboard
shows how many pages were
visited by users using each of
435 CSS properties.
You can see which properties
have been used or look at a
usage timeline of one
particular property.
Take a look and watch for more
dashing dashboards for Chrome
usage coming in the future.
Heading back into the cloud,
this week BigQuery added nifty
new features.
You can now analyze data in
real time by using the
tabledata.InsertAll call, very
useful when you need to know
what's going on right away.
BigQuery also added table
decorators, which are not
pretty centerpieces but a syntax
for enabling you to
query only a subset of the
newest data instead of the
full table.
And finally, we added a bunch
of new functions and new web
UI features.
Also, a big change for AdSense
developers this week.
AdSense now provides add code
that works with HTTPS.
This is more important than
ever now that browsers are
getting more aggressive about
warning or even blocking pages
with mixed secure and
standard content.
By using the new code in
either synchronous or
asynchronous flavors, you can
ensure that your pages won't
suffer this indignity.
And to make sure you don't
suffer the indignity of
missing a single thing from
the world of Google
Developers, subscribe to Google
Developers on YouTube
and check out the GDL schedule
at developers.google.com/live.
I'm Louis Gray, and I'll see
you back in the studio.